i'm just gonna let the tear drop because
it's all natural
when you when you cry it's natural from
heat
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we welcome
action bronson back to the hot seat
he's a rapper tv host chef and new york
times best-selling author
you of course know him from his show
[ __ ] that's delicious only for dolphins
is his album coming soon and to hold you
over the single latin grammys is
available now
bam bam welcome back to the show thank
you very much sir it's
so i'm so happy to see you it's good to
see you too how are you feeling going
into this you've done this a time before
but are you feeling a little bit nervous
you feel like it's old hat where you at
no everything is it's always new hat for
me i like it
i had some jerk chicken earlier
preparing myself i ate a couple
habaneros
so i think i'm ready i think
[Music]
i've learned that you have to humble
yourself in these situations
i love this label it's a great label by
the way
i like to buy hot sauces and all kinds
of different
different paraphernalia by the labeling
yeah it's kind of like uh it's kind of
like craft beer that way
for sure so i like the the funkier the
cover the better
so i'll be using i'm not gonna lie i'll
be using grilled chicken
because i'm off the fried things
[Music]
i'm gonna imagine crunch
i love that you could drink that a lot's
changed since i saw you last but the
most
obvious thing just looking at you is
this physical transformation that you've
made over quarantine losing close to a
hundred pounds
i see you on instagram doing dumbbell
presses and flipping tires
do you have specific power lifting goals
or is this all about making healthier
lifestyle choices
it's all about healthier lifestyle
choices but i like to use the
the exercises and the stuff that i like
to train
weights can get boring you know but when
you flip a tire you add a couple of
different things a circuit you do
something right after it
it's just a a more fun and interactive
way of training
and it's just crazy that i had a hundred
pounds to lose
in the first place and i'm still not
where i want to be
but that's my fault i did that
your music video for latin grammys has
that trademark throwback
action bronson appeal with these
strongman competitions and retro footage
who's your favorite strong man of all
time phil fister
well phil fisty he won that one year and
he he won
every event he's probably one of the
only strong men in history to win
every single event my favorite is marius
pujanowski
i study these men i this is something
that i've loved since i was a child you
know
it's something that always stays with
you it's like baseball cards it's like
playing mortal kombat watching world's
strongest man this is how i know about
the world
jani virtaninen yuko hola
you know what i mean vasil virastruk
[Music]
this is beautiful i like green hot
sauces you got to get a good spread
it's like wine you have to kind of
aerate it you know
you have to aerate you have to add a
little air to it
[Music]
we'll see how long you can keep that
going yeah
[Music]
some tomatillo action in there it's
really good
so on last week's episode adam richman
named you as the food guy with the most
credibility within rap and the thing
that i've always loved about [ __ ] that's
delicious
is it's a show that allows the fans the
viewers to go on a trip with you to all
these globe trotting adventures
where have you had more memorable
culinary experiences
tokyo or paris in paris i've done things
where i've
you know i was a headliner in front of
50 000 people in a park
and immediately i got off the stage and
got into a cab because they didn't have
my van ready for me
and i had no time to waste so i got in
one of those very little egg
cabs i had a suit
why i'll tell you because i went to a
three michelin star restaurant called
epicure it's brigade service it's like
old school
french service 20 people coming you know
you bring
chickens inside of the stomach of a pig
or some other [ __ ] like that
very very very ancient menu but
unbelievable
which is the superior american food city
in your opinion new orleans or chicago
oh [ __ ] they're both a 10.
they're both a 20. they're both places
that you need to go immediately
i'm just so sorry that that one hot dogs
is no longer there you know yeah it was
a legendary hot dog place in chicago
people would wait five hours online for
those things
and i got to taste every single one of
them oh
what a treat i used to live a few blocks
away from there so i'd see the line out
there
all the time you could get like a
rattlesnake hot dog and stuff
i had the forbidden one that was the
foie gras it was forbidden at a time he
wasn't allowed to serve it
so that with the duck sausage was very
memorable and it was like
some sort of french sauce on there one
of those mother sauces
or a derivative of
[Music]
i like the viscosity of this one it's a
creeper it's more sweet you know that's
the flavor of habanero right there
it gives you that sweet and then that
little that little creep
i like that lyrically you get a lot of
credit for your vivid food descriptions
and obscure sports references but one
thing that goes a little bit
under the radar is your clear and
obvious love of
film from mixtapes inspired by dr
hannibal lecter and blue chips
to 90s classics getting name checked in
rhyme
are the star wars films overrated in
your opinion i'm live from the moon you
rap
[ __ ] star wars indiana jones is better
[ __ ]
it's true it's true i i've
i don't think i've ever i mean i have
watched the star wars all the way
through but that's
it's a little bit um it's a little bit
too kitty you know i understand the
realm
and the the mind that it had it took to
create that
yeah i understand it i get it it's just
not as riveting to me as
indiana jones you know indiana jones is
just better to me than star wars
in my world it's a fact when you say
why the [ __ ] would i have a bodyguard if
i look just like the [ __ ]
bodyguard are you
trying to say that you have some
resemblance to kevin costner
that's really deep right there yes as a
matter of fact i do
and and
that's one of her best performances ever
no but
bodyguards they're like [ __ ] schlub
sometimes you know
i'm saying i look like you know this guy
that we were with in australia when we
went
on tour with eminem you know like some
[ __ ]
jacked up english guy that's low-key
and then finally is someone who's name
checked big trouble in little china and
has a song called sylvester lundgren
is there a tough guy movie you suggest
everyone watched during quarantine
yeah only the strong survive
it's a movie about capoeira and the dude
you know it's like a school teacher and
then he has to fight one of the students
uncles who's the drug dealer and he
always wears like crazy cowboy boots and
slacks and like a really
tight shirt you know with a ponytail
and you tail as old as time they do
capoeira which is like brazilian
dance fighting i think that that's one
of the best movies ever also
it's not a tough guy movie but you
should watch side out
you got a reaper on the cover and it's
only number four
hell yeah so on your white bronco tour
you completed more than a dozen
watercolor paintings on the theme of
weirdos across the country
are those based on real people because i
swear i did see ben franklin in one of
them
yeah that was actually buffalo bill but
yeah
definitely i mean went across this
country and you see some
creep shows and some amazing looks you
know if you ever look you have a look
you could be in a calvin klein thing you
could be in this type of thing whatever
those were near and dear to me that was
my first show i've ever done like
art wise i actually show i showed those
at my man jeremy fishes um gallery
in san francisco in north beach um
yeah man that was fun i sold a couple of
them i gave a couple away
just good times what do you say to
people who think that abstract art is
just squiggly lines and paint splatters
the way that you throw the splatter the
movement of your hand the movement of
your elbow
all these things could be deemed art if
you
capture it in the right way it's you
know so subjective
anything that moves
i like the color i like the smell mmm
some sweetness
[Music]
hell yeah we have a recurring segment on
our show called explain that gram where
we do a deep dive on our guests
instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so i'll show you the
picture
tell them please tell us the bigger
story do you have a favorite
memory from doing cece sabathia's
celebrity
softball game at yankee stadium wow
that's me i don't want to say that you
know what i'm doing
uh yes i have tremendous memories from
that
as a matter of fact cece sabathia good
friend of mine
is the one who got me hooked up with the
guy who i trained with now
he's the one who got me into the gym so
i
i accredited him with helping save my
life you know
i gave up a crazy home run to andrew
jones
i got gary sheffield to pop out i make a
ridiculous
athletic play off the mound throw the
ball
sidearm to mariano rivera who's playing
first base
gary sheffield with that stance you know
staring down the barrel of that stance
must have been something yeah well he
had a cigar in his mouth and he was
wearing jean
shorts as a connoisseur of natural
spirits
what's the appeal of natural wine to you
and then can you recommend some bottles
for those of us who may be new to the
game
the appeal of natural wine is that it
was explained to me in a poetic way this
it was the introduction to be honest
with you you know i'm not a i wasn't a
big wine drinker i don't like
traditional wines
even the biggest ones that are most
expensive it's tainted because it has
sulfites and different additives to
elongate its life natural wine is
exactly what it says natural people who
make it are
artists and their whole mind and life is
all about
making natural wine in its purest form
using nature only air
grape ah that's it
it's really the human factor i love
meeting the people i love knowing the
stories behind it i love seeing the
vineyards
you should just go to your natural wine
spot you should go to
my man uh discovery wines
in new york city call him up you know
what i'm saying
just be like listen bronson told me to
call you i need some help
ask for trevor those were actually two
bottles of natural
sake you have to get into it you have to
like get a little conversation going
then dive into it all right action
careful around the eyes are you ready to
move on here yeah don't you worry
don't you worry about these eyes these
eyes have seen some stuff my friend
this one is a dark one this is like that
honey
but you know like in hot sauces they
could always be just one note
bland but when you burn the chili
it gives it that that earthiness that
nuttiness that i look for
in a hot sauce and then life
you can taste the fire on that one
it immediately sets your hair on fire so
you've always been a multi-faceted
entertainer but i don't think even you
could have predicted speaking roles in
two of the year's most critically
acclaimed films
the irishman and king of staten island
how would you compare the experience of
working with judd apatow versus martin
scorsese they seem to be complete
opposites in the way that they operate
but i'm sure that there are character
traits that run through both
yeah i mean with judd it was just like
comedy on the sea on the set you know
just like they would throw you some
lines and
you'd say some crazy stuff you'd do it a
couple of times do it a couple of
different ways and
be crazy watch it back there was a lot
of people on set
watching back you know while it was
going on and laughing and they would
they would really get
they would get a feel for everything
from their friends and stuff like that
from the people that were around
as opposed to marty
he just told me go ahead you got this
gave me a hug that was that
he directed me like i'd want to be
directed and then de niro i [ __ ] up a
couple times he goes listen kid you're
[ __ ] everything up what are you doing
i thought he was serious
i was like i'm sorry man he's like come
here you [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm just joking
with you so that type of thing that
really you know
boosted my confidence i saw pesci at the
end i almost cried
just because i loved my cousin vinnie
that much it's one of your favorite
movies of all time 100
100 percent there's no doubt about it
and
the the irony of that is that marisa
tomei was in
staten island my dreams are fulfilled
don't [ __ ] cast me for anything ever
again i'm done
thor's hammer um
you know it doesn't pack that much of a
punch it's nice though damn
it's nice salute so i know that you're a
big fan of mick foley a guy who
inhabited entire personas like cactus
jack
mankind and dude love like he was a
method actor cause it's like daniel day
lewis
they take their [ __ ] real serious
they're not breaking their [ __ ] you know
uh you know i i was scared of the
undertaker when i was a kid
um i'm just gonna let the tear drop
because it's all natural
when you when you cry it's natural from
heat
it's your body's mechanism for cooling
itself down
randy savage captured me because he was
so intense
you know with the wild antics and the
wild
talk the way you he never broke it
that's who he was that's a man's man
right there
all right are you ready to move on this
next one is the bomb
beyond insanity i believe you've had
this one before it has a [ __ ] nuclear
bomb on it
ah man
i can't wait to work out after this
i feel like i'm in a sauna but a good
one you know like an
arabic sauna gotta get a good dab on
there don't be a [ __ ]
baby
all the hot ones have that initial like
you want to jump out the window flavor
kinda you know
it's uh immediately repulsive
yeah that was hot that's burning my
esophagus
[Music]
so i don't know if you've kept up with
the headlines but recently the pentagon
declassified
footage of military encounters with
unidentified aerial phenomena
as someone who was able to turn their
passion of ancient aliens into a
full-blown tv show
is there an archaeological discovery or
an unexplainable structure
that fascinates you what i learned was
when i was in kosovo that they found
something crazy over there
it's called the goddess on the
[Music]
goddess on the throne and it's this
little alien-like
subject that they just found so that
they find it in every corner of the
world
it's not this world was one piece at one
time
broken up
now
that's a creeper huh yeah yeah and it is
relentless
just shake it out
and i'd like to let them know that we're
waiting for them
all right well hopefully they're
watching this episode they are
action are you ready to move on to the
next one i am
the mono loco out of costa rica
i gotta [ __ ] blow my nose real quick
i'll be right back
[Music]
[ __ ] done got hotter
cheers
oh man that [ __ ] smells like pizza
sauce
it doesn't taste like pizza sauce no
so i know that you're making healthier
lifestyle choices these days
but do you have a recipe for the perfect
action bronson quarantine sandwich
i like turkey on my sandwich so i the
other day i roasted up some turkey
breast
paprika little garlic powder black
pepper salt
rub it real good a lot of olive oil
roasted in the oven at 400 for an hour
and a half two hours
and you have a beautiful specimen ready
to you know work
lay it with some of the juices more
olive oil a little more salt
a good pulmonary bread you know like a
good like loaf
i don't know why this [ __ ] gives me a
[ __ ] lisp
this is supposed to give you a lisp i
don't know we're in uncharted territory
all right so yeah black pepper mayo nice
smear avocado on the other side sliced
red onion real thin
turkey dress some greens with
some olive oil and some lemon little
salt
a roasted pepper red yellow green
whatever
some pickled jalapenos lime juice a
little oregano and salt
then cut it up real nice no
cheese just like that
trust me
my plate of hot sauce is art
looks like a jackson pollock from where
i'm sitting it is
cheers my bro thank you for having me
back cheers action thanks for coming
back
of course last dab
soaked
[Music]
a little more for [ __ ] good measure
oh
very caribbean all right action bronson
here we are at the conclusion of your
hot one
sequel and we've touched on your many
talents and interests but one thing that
we've missed
is billy joel he's sneakily one of the
most beloved
artists in hip-hop and i love that story
about you and mark ronson
sending that handwritten note to billy
joel's that he'd clear the sample for
zanzibar on your song brand new car
in as much detail as possible while
you're smoked out in more ways than one
why is billy joel in your words the
greatest lyricist
ever well listen you know
i have had a change of heart recently
not recently but
the [ __ ] played games with me
man he was supposed to bring me out at
madison square garden
he was gonna do zanzibar and then go
into my song
he they contacted my people this is all
guaranteed and this is all facts
i went on boomer and carton in the
morning it's a new york city [ __ ]
radio show sports show
and i was so excited i mentioned it and
what do you think
happened they plugged me up they pulled
the [ __ ] rug from right under me
how do you think i feel about billy joel
now i haven't listened to him since
you feel spurned right you just ate like
you just ate a wing
with the bomb on it that's probably how
it feels no
but obviously he's an amazing lyricist
man i you can never discredit his
lyricism
you know he brings you to a place of
familiarity we've all been to certain
places that he's taking us you know
that's that's why he's who he is
under the hottest hot sauces under the
sun
bronson cool calm collected
the second time around and now my friend
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you action bronson
this camera or possibly a camera b if
you've set one up
let the people know what you have going
on in your life [ __ ]
i have so many things going on in my
life
i just had a baby i just lost so much
weight
i'm working out like you can't believe
the tenacity that i
show in the gym is beyond i have a new
album coming out called oni for dolphins
new single out right now called latin
grammys
i made a cologne i have an ice cream
that's coming out called oni for
dolphins
i also have a wooden toy that's
self-sustainable and
good for the earth i also have all kinds
of other products that i'm not going to
just keep mentioning i paint i'm going
to have an art show soon
i'm just happy now i love everybody
showing you the best
thank you again for having me hot ones
familia
por vida you already know
essay for life
i wish i had a tank top on so i could
show you these [ __ ] guns
i like this was still my favorite flavor
that last
dab reminded me of the jerk that i made
earlier it was really good i had some
nice
allspice notes in this caribbean
so there might not even be all spice in
there maybe i'm just [ __ ] lying
but i'll tell you this this is a really
great array
this is a good diverse bunch of hot
sauces to really
take it up someone's ass
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in
with one camera guy how you doing steven
you good good steven's good there's no
one else in this building except for the
two of us
it is locked down over here but you know
what the pepperdome is open for all new
episodes of hot ones the game show
tuesdays on truetv the pepperdome
see you there if you dare